Traducteur: Edith Félicité Koumtoudji
Relecteur: Céline Hérion
Bonjour.
Sur cette photo, nous avons
5 jeunes de la Caravelle,
un quartier sensible du 92
à Villeneuve-la-Garenne,
qui sont en train de donner un cours
à 20 étudiants de HEC.
Comme vous pouvez le constater,
il ne s'agit pas d'un cours de slam,
il s'agit d'un cours de langue,
une langue qui permet
de donner des ordres
à des machines et à des ordinateurs,
la langue du 21e siècle :
le code informatique.
Et ces jeunes de Villeneuve
ont été formés par Simplon.
SIMPLON est né en 2013
d'un constat simple:
il y a 5 millions de chômeurs en France
face à ça, des milliers d'opportunités
et d'emplois à pourvoir
dans le domaine du développement Web
et de la programmation informatique.
Et malgré ça,
le code, ça ne s'apprend toujours pas
à l'école. Il faut y être formé.
Et nous, on savait qu'il n'y avait
pas besoin d'être ingénieur
pour être formé au code.
On a donc imaginé une formation intensive,
gratuite, par la pratique,
voire financée par des bourses.
On l'a imaginée gratuite
car on la destine
à des personnes éloignées de l'emploi
ou, plus globalement,
à des profils qui demeurent
sous-représentés dans le numérique.
La première promotion de simploniens,
en septembre 2013,
c'était 30 personnes de 18 à 52 ans
dont 75% de demandeurs d'emplois
et de bénéficiaires de minimas sociaux,
50% de personnes originaires
de quartiers populaires
et 30% de femmes,
car il y a encore trop peu
de développeuses.
Quand on a ouvert Simplon à Montreuil,
on nous a dit qu'on n'y arriverait pas,
que ce serait impossible de former
des débutants, des non-diplômés,
des demandeurs d'emploi, sur du code.
Mais ces profils-là, on les a choisi
sans concession,
sur la base de tests
qui mettaient à l'épreuve leur envie
et leur motivation car,
s'il n'y a pas besoin d'être ingénieur,
en revanche, il faut être déterminé,
persévérant et débrouillard.
Ces profils-là, on ne les a pas choisis
que sur critères sociaux.
On les a choisis
parce qu'ils ont toutes les qualités
pour devenir développeurs.
Aujourd'hui, Simplon accueille
sa deuxième promotion à Montreuil.
Roxanna, une ancienne élève,
a ouvert un Simplon en Roumanie ;
Rodolphe, un ancien élève lui-aussi,
a formé les 15 jeunes
de Villeneuve-la-Garenne.
Hier, c'était la première rentrée
dans "Simplon Village"
à la Loupe, dans le Perche,
en zone rurale
[Notre école est ici]
car sur ces territoires aussi,
le numérique peut devenir
un levier d'inclusion puissant.
En 2015, on est bien partis pour ouvrir
3 autres Simplon en zones rurales,
ainsi qu'un en Tunisie
et un en Afrique du Sud.
On nous a dit qu'il serait impossible
de former intensivement, gratuitement,
surtout des profils atypiques
pour le domaine.
Pourtant, les simploniens
nous ont prouvé le contraire.
Ils nous ont prouvé
qu'on avait bien fait
de croire en leur potentiel
et d'aller chercher des talents
là où on ne voit souvent
que des difficultés.
On nous a dit
qu'on ne pouvait pas le faire.
À ce jour,
tout ce que nous pouvons répondre,
c'est qu'on ne pouvait pas
ne pas le faire.
Merci.
(Applaudissements)